Hi
Oh my goodness.
I have never seen another person
hold my book until this moment,
until I was like oh my God
the first time I'm seeing someone
hold my book it's Drew Barrymore.
Oh my gosh I'm not kidding.
When we first started the show and I wanted to
describe the conversations that I wanted to have.
I kept talking about you.
I'm such a longtime fan,
and your poetry is so important and meaningful,
and you have hooked so many people with it with poetry.
And I just think that it's so extraordinary.
Do you have any objectivity on why
what you put out there resonates so much with people?
You know, I think that poetry in general is the easiest
and can at times maybe be the freest form of therapy
a person can get that day
because for the most part
it's a really emotion focused way of communicating.
And there's so many spaces where they tell us
don't bring your emotions.
You know, don't be emotional.
I think especially as women we've cut
off so much of ourselves in order to try to progress
into certain spaces
and that's changing a lot now.
But I think that poetry as always saying like,
your heart belongs in this room,
your heart belongs in this conversation.
Your heart belongs in this communication.
And so, you know I just feel so grateful
that people have allowed
for my poetry to maybe be an entry point
into going into the genre at all.
I have so many people who are like,
I hated poetry but I loved Heart Talk,
or you know I never thought I'd like it or get into it.
And I think that for me you know,
whether it's through my writing for poetry
or activism in any form.
I'm always just looking for the easiest on-ramp,
or entry point to get people involved
and in touch with themselves.
Well you have a beautiful new daughter, Memphis.
Yes.
And you dedicated this book to her?
And by the way I love your man, Simon.
I was lucky enough to work
with him on Charlie's angels,
back in the day.
And now you have this beautiful new daughter together.
Memphis who's just turned a year.
Is that correct?
Yeah she's about a year and two months so.
And now you wrote this beautiful new children's book.
I can't think of a better pairing
than Cleo Wade and a children's book.
It's called What The Road Said.
May I ask again what your light bulb moment was
for creating this book?
You know when I first started the journey of this book
it's so interesting because I really started writing it,
I think for my childhood self.
I wasn't pregnant when I started this book.
And I really you know,
I just remember in my own childhood just feeling
like there was so many times where I felt so alone,
or there were these really big questions I had
and no one really had the answers
to them or was even afraid to voice them.
And I wondered if there was more out there.
I wondered how to use my voice.
I wondered how to find or understand bravery
or vulnerability or all these things that we still
even struggle with as adults.
And so I wanted to write something that was
like a healing balm to my childhood self.
And then halfway through the process I got pregnant,
and it was so crazy because this journey that started
for my own childhood healing ended up
becoming a book for my daughter.
And so the this book is so personal
and so emotional for me.
I seriously I still I've been started doing interviews
about it like two weeks ago.
And I almost cry every time because you know it really is.
It's everything you know it's every
thing I hope my daughter can know in her life.
And it's everything I hope that every young girl
or young person you know,
it's something I wish they could all have truly.
I'm so proud of this.
And so it's a really emotional book for me,
but I'm so excited to put it put it out.
Well, I'm sure your daughter will marvel
with parents like you and Simon.
And I think that we're all looking
for the takeaways in life.
It's so important.
And your work is so full of them.
Thank you so much.
Um I just can't even believe you just said that to me.
So thank you so much.
Thank you so much Cleo Wade for coming here to talk
about your children's book,
which I again was like,
oh that's the most potent combination.
What The Road Said is available now
in stores and online wherever books are sold.
Thank you so much.
Say hi to Simon and,
I will!
And hello to beautiful Memphis.
(upbeat outro music)